Ciao mi chiamo Giselda ho 34 anni vengo
da Pieve del Grappa provincia di Treviso
Viva il Veneto fate l'operaia saluta
tanto i miei colleghi così quando mi
vedono mi dicono che [__] che te Sì alla
mia più grande passione se è la montagna
camminare camminare camminare vedete i
miei poveri cassetti a forza di
camminare I sega ha distrutto Mamma mia
che puzza io non li ho mai messi Italia
Avrò messo una volta sola così tanto pe'
poi dall'otorino per esempio non sono
mai andata in tutta la vita però tutti i
miei parenti va spesso a controllare
Corona Uffa benissimo Mauro Eh se mi
sposo mi sposo solo con Montanaro gente
proprio che sa da montagna che che
espulsa delletame che si porta la legna
sulle spalle che parla coi mucche mi
sento un po' pesce fuor d'acqua Perché
vengo da un mondo diverso dalla montagna